[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي الاختيار استهلوها بابره
العناوين
حرب الظل بين ايران واسرائيل تعود الى
البحار واتهامات متبادله بالهجوم على
ناقله نفط قباله سواحل عمان
ايران
اشخاص على اراضيها
بولندا
ناس تؤرخ عصرا شديدا وتنجح في اطلاق
صاروخها لنقل البشر
[موسيقى]
تنتقل الى مؤتمر لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
على كافه المناطق المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
ولكنها قد خسرت وروسيا لن تحقق اي من
الاهدافها وقد اخفقت في تحقيق اهدافها
الاستراتيجيه والان تخفق ايضا في تحقيق
اهدافها العمليه العمليه لقد غيرت روسيا
من طبيعه الحرب التي اختارتها وركزت على
منطقه الدمبس واللوجانز
كان هذا هو هدفها العمليه واخفقت هناك ومن
تم غيرت مره اخرى وتوسعت
لتقوم بسيطره
واعاده تقطير اهدافها
وغزوها غير القانوني كلهم مجتمعين
في الاسبوع الماضي
لقد انسحبت الى نهر دنيبر لتكون في موقع
دفاعيه جنوب النهر وخسائر وروسيا امام
النجاح الاوكراني وشجاعتهم في ميدان
المعركه كان امرا لا يخفى على الناظر ومن
الواضح ان
القدرات العسكريه الامريكيه القدرات
العسكريه الروسيه لا تضاهي نظيرتها
الاوكرانيه لكن القوات الاوكرانيه قد حققت
نجاحا كبيرا واستطاعت ان تتوجهها في
معركتها النحو منطقه الشرق مدينه الشرق
ما يحدث في بخمه الان وفي
سبينس والقوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل بطريقه
ناجحه من خلال عمليه دفاعيه متحركه
على الخطوط الاماميه برمتها اكثر من التي
تصل الى 900 كيلومتر الاخرى والاخر تلو
الاخر والروس فشلوا في كل مره فقد فقدوا
وخسروا على واستراتيجي والمستوى العمليتي
وعلى المستوى التكتيكي
وقد كل وكل المحاولات التي بداوا بها قد
فشلت شرعوا في هذه الحرب وبمقدور روسيا ان
تنهيها بمقدور روسي ان تتخذ خيارا اخر ان
تتخذ قرار
باسدال لستار هذه الحرب لكن روسيا اختارت
ان تقوم باعاده التجميع الصفوف قواتها
وتقوم بفرض حمله مروعه حمله
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى جزء من مؤتمر
صحافه لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه سمعنا
خلالها الجنرال مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه هيئه
الاركان المشتركه
[موسيقى]
وصل ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه في زياره رسميه
وتعد هذه الزياره الثانيه لولي العهد
السعودي الى سول خلال ثلاث سنوات ملفات
اقتصاديه كبرى ستكون على جدول الزياره
بحضور كبرى الشركات الكوريه ورجال الاعمال
وذلك لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طبعا سنعود للسياق هذه
الزياره وتفاصيلها خلال سياق التاسعه
[موسيقى]
بدايه التاسع من حرب البحار وتهديد
الملاحه الدوليه في الهجوم بمسيره على
ناقله نفط قباله ساحل عمان اعتبرته
اسرائيل استفزازا ايرانيا وخطا استراتيجيا
ارتكبه النظام الايراني بحسب ما نقل صحيفه
هارات عن مسؤولين امنيين اسرائيليين وقال
مسؤول اسرائيلي ان المسيره المستخدمه في
الهجوم على ناقله النفط هي نفسها التي يتم
توريدها لروسيا واستخدامها في اوكرانيا
ايران من جانبها حملت اسرائيل مسؤوليه
الهجوم على الناقله المملوكه لرجل اعمال
اسرائيلي اما واشنطن فقد حملت ايران
مسؤوليه الهجوم على ناقله نفط قباله عمان
وقال مستشار الامن القومي للجهاز سوليفان
ان الهجوم هو احدث الاعمال والانشطه
المزعزي على الاستقرار ولا مبرر له مضيفا
ان ايران نفذته الهجوم بواسطه مسيره مؤكدا
ان واشنطن ستعمل مع الحلفاء لمحاسبه ايران
والرد عليها عبر الوسائل المناسبه
[موسيقى]
سنعود طبعا لمتابعه متابعات هذه هذا
الهجوم الايراني ولكن خلال سياق التسعه
وفوره جهود ضيفنا
بخبر اخر اعلن المدير العام للمخابرات
البريطانيه الداخليه كان مقال قوله ان
ايران خططت لخطف واغتيال 10 مقيمين في
بلاده تتهمهم بانهم اعداء للنظام كما اشار
الى اتجاه ايران لتنفيذي هجمات ارهابيه
على الاراضي البريطانيه وقال ان موجه
الاحتجاجات الحاليه دفعت النظام الايراني
لللجوء الى العنف لاسكات المنتقدين واضاف
ان ايران نقلت التهديد الى بريطانيا
مباشره من خلال من خلال اجهزه المخابرات
التابعه لها وقال راينا 10 تهديدات محتمله
على الاقل خلال شهر واحد
ينضم الينا من لندن كاظم والي الصحفي
المختص في الشان الايراني استاذ كاظم سجل
الحرب الحقيقيه بين لندن وطهران حافل بدا
يعني سمعنا بالايام الماضيه التهديد
للمعارضين هناك واليوم كشفت الحكومه عن
هذا التهديد بمحاولات اغتيال هل ممكن ان
تنقل طهران الصراع الدبلوماسي مع الغرب
الى مرحله الاغتيالات بهذا التوقيت بالذات
التحياتي لك ولي المشاهدين العربيه النظام
الايراني لديه تاريخ حاصل في عمليات
الاغتيال والتصفيه المعارضين السياسيين في
الخارج وهذه بدات هذه السياسه المنهجه
بدات فور وصول الخميني بسله الحكم في
ايران في عام 1979
وهذه السياسه مستمر
قبل تقريبا عام 1
قامت مؤسسه برومان الحقوق الانسان
الايرانيه بالنشر تقرير مفصل عن 540
محاوله اغتيال
وخطفون سياسيين في الخارج اغلبهم كانت
كانوا في في اوروبا همم اعتقد ان العامل
الاساس يعني هذه الاستمرار في هذه
العمليات همم الايرانيه في الدول الغربيه
وفي الخارج وعدم الرد الحاسم لهذه الدول
على هذه الاعمال الادائيه مره يتم
نعم هل تكفي العقوبات التي تفرضها الدول
الغربيه من وقت لاخر على النظام
الامور بريطانيا على سبيل المثال من خلال
هذا الاعلان اعتقد انها تحاول ان ترسل
رساله لايران بان هذه المره لن تسكت على
هذه الاعمال العدائيه على اراضيها
وسيتم حسبت ايران ومن ضمن هذه
الافعال الممكن الردود الفعل البريطانيه
ممكن ادراج الحرس الثوري على قائمه العراق
البريطانيه وهنا بالفعل مطالبات برلمانيه
لادراج الحرس الثوري على قائمه الارهاب
البريطانيه وهناك هذا مستمر يعني موجود في
همم سعر الدول الاوروبيه ايضا تدرس هذا
الخيار للادراج الحرس الدوري لانه هو
الاساس في هذه العمليات في الخارج
سينعكس هذا الصراع اليوم او هذه الازمه
الدبلوماسيه بين الطرفين على الموقف من
الاتفاق النووي خصوصا ان موقف بريطانيا
كان متشددا اذا ما قررناه بموقف التريكا
اي فرنسا المانيا وطبعا بريطانيا هي
الثالثه بالموقف الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
تحاول من خلال هذا الاعلان بالاساس هو كان
من خلاله بانه رساله واضحه للنظام
الايراني
مع هذه الاعمال وممكن ان تنسحب من الاتفاق
اللي هو مع ايران وهذا ايضا ممكن ان يكون
مطروح اذا لم تتجاوب همم
يتجاوب النظام الايراني مع مطالبات همم
الغرب في قضيه الملف الايرانيه ممكن ان
تسحب هذه الدول
وبالفعل هذا ممكن ان يحصل كما ممكن ان
يضعوا عقوبات جديده على همم افراد وشخصيات
ومؤسسات ايرانيه مرتبطه بهذه الاعمال
الادائيه في في الغرب او في الاحتجاجات في
همم
اليوم من المعروف ان النظام يواجه ازمه
عجز امام تظاهرات الشارع هل ممكن ان يذهب
الى يعني درجه الاغتيالات للضغط على
الانظمه الغربيه
لايقاف الدعم المعنوي التكنولوجي السياسي
لكل المتظاهرين في ايران
الداخليه للخارج وربط هذه الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه المناهضه لنظام ولي الفقيه
والمطالبه بسقاط النظام الايراني والتي
مستمر خلال شهرين
وتتصاعد هذه الاحتجاجات دائما النظام
الايراني يسعى الى تصدير هذه او رابط هذه
الاحتجاجات باطراف دوليه ومحليه في الايام
الماضيه الحرس الثوري عن القاء القبض على
مجموعات مرتبطه باجهزه استخبارات غبيه كما
قام
الحرس الثوري همم ضربات صاروخيه ضد مواضع
همم اكراد همم المواقع العسكريه لاكراد
ايران في العراق وهذا هو بالاساس لتصدير
هذه ال- ال- ال- المشكله الى الخارج
وربطها بالخارج حتى يتم همم هذه المظاهرات
واعطاء مبرر همم القمع هذه المظاهرات في
الداخل وايضا تصفيه المعرضين المهم همم في
في الخارج ايضا لما يشكلون من دعم طبعا
ايضا للمتظاهرين شكرا لك استاذ كاظم والي
الصحفي المختص في شان الايراني حدثتنا من
ايران من لندن عفوا وفي الداخل الايراني
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو اضراب اصحاب المحلات
التجاريه واغلاقها امام المتسوقين في اغلب
المدن الايرانيه وعلى راسها طهران وذلك
تنفيذا لاضراب شامل في ذكرى قمع احتجاجات
عام 2019
فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات جديده على
شخصيات وكيانات مرتبطه بايران منها عقوبات
على موظفي التلفزيون الايرانيه من جهتها
فرضت كندا ايضا عقوبات على ايران على
خلفيه قمح على احتجاجات وتزويد روسيا
بمسيرات في اوكرانيا شامله سته افراد
وكيانين اثنين
عبر الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه البالغ تجاه
انشطه ايران النوويه وابتعادها عن
الاستخدام المدني وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي
امام مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه المنعقد بمقر الوكاله انه قلق من
ان ايران تواصل تصعيد برنامجها النووي الى
ما هو ابعد من اي مبرر مقبول للاستخدام
المدني على الرغم من اعلانها الالتزام
بالاتفاق النووي واضاف ناسف لان ايران
حولت برنامجها النووي الى اداه سياسيه
مشيرا الى ان التنفيذ الكامل والمتحقق منه
للالتزامات الايرانيه المتعلقه بالمجال
النووي امر لا غنى عنه وحسن الاتحاد
الاوروبي ايران على الامتناع عن اي خطوات
تصاعديه اخرى وتراجع عن كافه الانشطه التي
تتعارض مع الاتفاق النووي
[موسيقى]
اذا وصل ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه في زياره
رسميه وتعاد هذه الزياره الثانيه لولي
العهد السعودي الى سول خلال ثلاث سنوات
ملفات اقتصاديه كبرى ستكون على جدول
الزياره بحضور كبرى شركات الكوريه ورجال
الاعمال وذلك لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذا هذه الصور الاوليه التي وصلتنا قبل
قليل لاصول ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان ضمن جولته الاسيويه الى كوريا
الجنوبيه حيث سيعقد طبعا منتدى غدا على
هامشي هذه الزياره سيتم فيه توقيع
اتفاقيات اقتصاديه بين الجانبين
[موسيقى]
نزع على النت وبولاندا فتيل الشعار لتصعيد
مع روسيا وحسما كل منهما بان الصاروخين
على بولندا بسبب ضربه روسيه وقال امين عام
الناتو ينز ان لا دلائل تشير الى ان
الهجوم في بولندا كان متعمدا واكد ان
تحليلات الاوليه تشير الى ان الهجوم في
بولندا تم بصواريخ دفاعيه اوكرانيه
ليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان هذا كان نتيجه
هجوم متعمد وليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان
روسيا تستعد لعمليات عسكريه هجوم
» تحليلنا الاولي يشير الى ان الحادثه كان
على الارجح بسبب صاروخ دفاع جوي اوكراني
تم اطلاقه للدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ضد هجمات صواريخ الروسيه لكن اسمحوا لي ان
اوضح هذا ليس خطا اوكرانيا روسيا تتحمل
المسؤوليه النهائيه لانها تواصل حربها غير
القانونيه ضد اوكرانيا
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان اكياف
تستغل كل فرصه لالقاء اللوم عروس على
روسيا ومحاوله تعزيز الدعم الغربي كما وصف
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي بمتر مدافاف
الهجوم الصاروقي على بولندا بانه دليل على
ان الغرب يسعى الى حرب عالميه وقال في
تغريده له ان واقعه الضرب الصاروخيه التي
تروج لها اوكرانيا على الاراضي البولنديه
تثبت سعيها بكل السبل لشن حرب عالميه ضد
روسيا مضيفا ان الحرب الهجينه التي ينخرط
فيها الغرب تقرب او تقرب من حدوث هذه
السنه ارجوكم
وابهرت صوره للشرطه البولنديه في موقع
حفره بجوار مركبه مقلوبه في موقع الانفجار
في منطقه حدوديه الصوره تبرز اثار الصاروخ
الذي سقط على منشات حبوب بولنديه مما اسفر
عن مقتل شخصين وهو الحادث الذي اثار طبعا
قلقا عالميا من ان حرب اوكرانيا يمكن ان
تنتقل الى البلدان المجاوره
في بولندا وبعد حاله الاستغفار القصوى على
خلفيه سقوط صاروخين على اراضيها العديد من
المسؤولين الغربيين يؤكدونا بان ما حدث
سببه نظام السباقي عسكري اوكراني وتحديدا
صاروخ موجه مضاد للطائرات يعود لنظام
فمع تصاعد التوتر الى مستويات قسوه خلال
الساعات الماضيه اكدت روسيا ان الهدف من
كل ما حصل هو اثاره صراع محل شمل الاطلسي
وهنا الشهاده
الولايات المتحده المحسود على حادث
الصاروخ البولندي في خطوه تدعم فكره ان
الصاروخ اطلق من الاراضي الاوكرانيه مقدرا
ضبط النفس الامريكيه حيث كشف المسؤولون
امريكيون انا القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت
الصاروخ الذي ضرب هولندا وذلك لا اعتراض
صاروخ روسيا
يا باشا
اطلق من روسيا لا اريد تاكيد ذلك الا بعد
التحقيق الكامل لكن حسب مسار الصاروخ من
غير المرجح ان يكون اطلق من روسيا لكننا
سنرى لاحقا
ردت وقالت
بان 30 كيلو متر من الحدود الاوكرانيه
البولنديه وبان حطام الصاروخين اللذين سقط
في بولندا يعود لنظام 3 لاوكرانيا في غضون
ذلك اعتبر الرئيس الاوكراني
حادثه صاروخ بولندا رساله من روسيا الى
قمه العشرين هذا وكان ذلك قد اعتبر ان
الحادث تصعيد كبير وتهديد للامن العالمي
ويستدعي تحرك الحلف
لقد حدث اليوم ما كنا نحذر منه لفتره
طويله لقد قلنا ان الارهاب لا يقتصر على
حدود دوله فحسب اليوم ضربت صواريخ روسيه
راضيه بولندا الدوله الحديثه التهديدات
الروسيه بات تستهدف جميع منهم في مرمى
الصواريخ الروسيه
درجه من الحذر بشان مصدر الصاروخ الذي سقط
في بولندا محذره من خطر على حد وصفها في
ما اعتبر المستشار الالماني
انه من الضروري التحقق من كيفيه حدوث هذه
الحادثه المروعه في حين دعت الصين طبعا
جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس اما بلجيكا
فلقد قالت وبصريح العباره على لسان وزير
الخارجياتها بان الصاروخ مصدره اوكرانيا
اما الخارجيه الاوكرانيه فلقد استنكرت
الموقف الروسي في اشاره الى ان ما حصل
يمكن ان يفتح باب حرب جديده مع حرف الناتو
غير بولندا صاحبه الشان والمعنيه بما جرى
على اراضيها بدت غير محببه للدفاعات
اوكرانيا تجاهها تحميل روسيا ما حصل
روسيا
روسيا هاجمت اوكرانيا
اطلق الصواريخ لتحييد هذا الهجوم الروسي
تشير تقديرات الى انه تم اسقاط نصف
الصواريخ الروسيه
الارضيه الاوكرانيه لسوء الحظ من المحتمل
جدا ان يكون احد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه قد سقط على
اراضينا والارجح انه لم يكن انفجارا
للصاروخ نفسه لكن من المحتمل
الوقود المتبقي فيه ربما يكون صاروخ اس
300 صنع في الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو صاروخ
قديم ولا يوجد دليل على انه اطلق من
الجانب الروسي
اذا اكثر من موقف ينزل مسؤوليات روسيا لكن
ما جرى اعاد الحديث عن تفعيل مبدا الدفاع
الجماعي لحلف الاطلسي والذي يعتبر بموجبه
الهجوم على احد اعضاء التحالف هجوما على
الجميع مما يؤدي الى بدء المشاورات حول رد
عسكريا المحتمل خصوصا وان دول عده في
المنطقه تمتلك النوع نفسه من الاسلحه
معتبره ان تحديد نوع الصاروخ لا يعني
بالضروره تحديد الجهه التي اطلقت
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا عبر الزوم من وارسو كشفتوف
بلوميسكي اديب رومانسي السابق استاذ امام
حديث الرئيس البولندي عن يعني عدم وجود
دليل على ان روسيا هي من قامت بهذا الهجوم
وامام الموقف البولندي المتزن اين اصبحت
التحقيقات وماذا كشفت حتى الساعه
مساء الخير التحقيقات مستمره
ويبدو هذه الدقيقه
في الحقيقه العظمه العظمه الجديده خطيره
جدا لو كان
ضربه على امس بصاروخ في الاراضي البولنديه
عمل
متعمدا من روسيا وهذا يعني ليندا روسيا
تريد
الحقيقيه ليس فقط
على بوابه
من سيقوم بهذا التحقيق
ايه هذا التحقيق
مستقل
بمشاركه الخبراء البولنديين ومشاركته
خبراء من الولايات المتحده
وغيرها من الدول
نحن لا نتسرع في بولندا في هذه التحقيقات
نحتاج الوقت
تحديد يعني بالدقه كل الملبوسات يعني اللي
ما حصل
اليوم يعني ما هو معلوم ان مثلث العلاقات
البولنديه الاوكرانيه الروسيه معقد نوعا
ما تاريخيا وحتى الساعه هل بولندا امام
موقف متزن من هذه الحرب بالرغم من دعمه
لاوكرانيا منعا لتصعيده وخروج وخارج
الحدود الاوكرانيه
ايه نحن
جيراننا وجيراند في روسيا وفي الحقيقه
بتاريخ كبير يعني
اشتقنا الحرب يعني لو كان من روسيا الحرب
الحقيقيه
كيف يعني هذا العمليه الخاصه
الروسيه لو كان يعني حتى امس سقوط همم
تقريبا 100 صاروخ
روسيات يعني
قبل كل شيء ضد البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
وخاصه يعني في مجال الطاقه ونحن
نقترب الى الشتاء
والشتاء انتم تعرفون يعني في اوروبا
وخصوصا يعني في اوكرانيا وبولندا
وبروده ممكن يكون يعني 20 25
[موسيقى]
نعم
امام هذا الواقع الصعب هناك ايضا حديث عن
نقل قوات جديده من حلف انيته الى المنطقه
الشرقيه كيف سيتم هذا الموضوع وهل نتحدث
عن يعني تحشيد اكبر على الحدود هناك
[موسيقى]
عدد من القوات
الامريكيه قررت ارتفاع
عادات لبعض الوحدات العسكريه والشرقيه في
بولندا وايضا يعني نتوقع
وصول مزيد من
الخبراء وحدات يمين العسكريه من دول
الناقه وهذا كيف يعني هذا مهم ف- همم
وجدنا امس لان همم
تحدثنا في البدايه حول تحقيق يعني في بعض
في سقوط الصاروخ امس كان كان اييي من
الممكن تحديث يعني بعده لتفاصيل يعني
بيخصوص سير اييه
الصاروخ بسبب وجود تغيرات الامريكيه من
تراث هواكس اللي تراقب الاجواء ليس فقط
يعني فوق بولندا بس ايضا في البنات
والاشهر المقبله شكرا لك استاذ
دبلوماسي السابقه
في اقليم دوم بس افادت وسائل الاعلام
تابعه للقوات المواليه لروسيا بان الجيش
الاوكراني يتكبد خسائر فادحه خلال الساعات
الاخيره في صفوف الافراد والمعدات
العسكريه نتيجه العمليات الهجوميه الناشطه
للقوات الروسيه حيث لا قد هي 70 جنديا
مصرعهم في اشتباكات مع مقاتلي جمهوريه
لوغان التي ضمتها روسيا كما تم تدمير خمس
ناقلات جنود مدرعه وثلاث طائرات بدون طيار
كانت تستخدمها القوات الاوكرانيه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في العراق هيئه النزاهه تشكل لجنه للتحقيق
في الفساد
[موسيقى]
مستبقا الجميع
حمله الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
متحديا الجميع داخل وخارج حزب هل يؤكد
ترشحه ان المعركه داخل حزب الجمهوري ستكون
طاحنه برغم ان غالبيه استطلاعات الراي
ترجع فوزي ترامب في الانتخابات التمهيديه
للحزب الجمهوري موقف اعضاء الحزب من خطوه
ترامب تتضارب رغم الوعود برسم صوره مثاليه
لامريكا جديده في المرحله المقبله
فالجمهوريون يرون بان ترامب لن يكون قادرا
على لاعب ادوار سياسيه مهمه في المرحله
المقبله بسبب الفشل الذريه الذي تم تسجيله
في الانتخابات التجديد النصفي فراغ ما انه
لا يزال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره الا ان بعض
جمهوريين بانه كان السبب في التصدعات التي
يشهدها الحزب بدعمه لبعض المرشحين دون
الاخر في الانتخابات الاخيره فترام ولد
اعلانه عن ترشحه انتقد سياسه الرئيس
اتهم اهو بالفشل في اداره البلاد وبانه
السبب في التردد الوضع الاقتصادي وارتفاع
وتيره التضخم غير ان بيدن رد بالقول ان
ترامب خذل بلاده خلاله وليه منصبه وخلال
رئاسته تربع على اقتصاد مزور لصالح
الاثرياء وهاجم النظام الصحي ودلل
المتطرفين وهاجم حقوق المراه وحرض
العصابات العنيفه
ان يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليها قبل عامين
كنا امه عظيمه وقريبا سنكون امه عظيمه من
جديد
بان المرحله المقبله ستكون ساخنه وصعبه
لدى الجمهوريين خصوصا وانا الحزب يشهد
فوضى كبيره على الصعيد الداخلي فخذت ترامب
وفقه وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه عرضها
العديد من الجمهوريين الذين دعوا ترامب
لتاجيل اعلانه الترشح الى ما بعد جوله
الاعاده في مجلس الشيوخ في جورجيا الشهر
المقبل غير انه تجاوز كل الاستشارات التي
قدمت له فترام هذه المره لا يستهدف فقط
بيضا مراقبين فليسع ايضا لتحطيم فرص
منافسيه المحتملين بمن فيهم ديسانتس
ونائبه السابق وبالتالي فان اشد حلفاء
ترامب سيرفضون تقديم الدعم والتاييد له في
المرحله المقبله كما ان تسربت ايضا
معلومات تفيد بان وزاره العدل الامريكيه
تريد توجيهتها من الرئيس السابق ترامب
قضيه الوثائق السريه التي قد تعرقل مسار
حملته الانتخابيه المقبله
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الحسين الطاوضه
مراسل العربيه حسين كيف هي الاجواء بعد
يعني اعلان ترامب لترشحي الانتخابات ماذا
عن ردود الفعل الجمهوريه وكيف يعني
الانقسام باي طرف وكيف بدا
تحيه لك ليال بالفعل هذا الخبر هو الخبر
الشاغر هنا في الولايات المتحده لاسيه ما
داخل الحزب الجمهوري كما تفضلت الانقسام
باقى واضحا بين من يرى بان ترامب في ترشحه
هذا هو سيعلن فشل الحزب في الانتخابات عام
2014 وبين من يرى انه يجب ان يترشح ولكن
متى من الواضح جدا ان العديد من قاده
الحزب الجمهوري همم يريدون ان ينروا
بانفسهم عن ترابيو يبتعدون عنه لاسيما في
بعد
النتائج التي وصفت بضعيفه لمرشحين ترامب
خلال الانتخابات التشديد النصفي معظمهم
تقريبا فشل في همم يحصل على مقادمه في
مجلس الشيوخ او مجلس النواب او حتى على
مستوى مناصب الحكام وكل ذلك ايضا في ظل
همم سطوع نجم ال- ال- الحاكم حاكم فلوريدا
رمز الذي يرى فيه الكثيرون انه همم لديه
الافضليه في ان ينتخب كرئيس مترشح كرئيس
لو انت اخذ كرئيس الولايات المتحده عن
الحسبه الجمهوري بعد النتائج التي وصفت
بالقويه التي حققها خلال الانتخابات
الجدول بين الجمهوريين همم كبير جدا هنا
انقسام واضح جدا ولكن اضافه الى
الجمهوريين البارحه كان هناك هجوم من
الديمقراطيين ايضا على دونالد ترامب ولعل
ابرز همم كشفت عنه هذه المره صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز هو ان مستشاري للرئيس منذ
نحو عام بداوا يحضرون الاستراتيجيه
لمواجهه هجمات دونالد ترامب على اداره
الرئيس بايدا وعلى انها فشلت كما اا اعلن
البارحه خلال خطابه الذي هاجم في اداره
الوقايه منها ضعيفه وان ان في عهد كان
الاقتصاد جيدا هناك الان خليه عمل حسن
كشفت همم نيويورك داخل اداره للرد على
هكذا هجمات من الرئيس السابق طبعا
شكرا لك يا حسن الصوت مراسل العربيه
حدثتنا من واشنطن
وينضم الينا من واشنطن ايضا الدكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه دكتور وليد يعني نحن امام خامس
رئيس امريكي يعلن عزمه العوده الى السلطه
هل ممكن ان يفعلها ترامب ويعود وتكون
الاستثناء الثاني بتاريخ السياسه
الامريكيه
الان في هذا الشهر وهذا العام انما قد
يجري بعد عامين من الان ولكن يمكن القول
انه ما اراده ترامب حصل عليه ولو لم يقوله
اولا حصل على مجلس نيابي وحتى لو امل
بمجلس الشيوخ ولكن مجلس النيابي هاوس
افريكانو يسيطر على المال وهذا كبير جدا
في الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه اثنين هو
اراد وحصل على ترشيح نفسه قبل كل الاخرين
ليحاول قطع الطريق عنهم الان هذا ايضا فيه
نقاط ضعف لانه يقوم بذلك يهاجم بعض حلفائه
الجمهوريين ومنهم كما تفضلتهم حاكم
فرجينيا همم
واشخاص اخرين في الحزب الجمهوري هو
باعتقاد مجبور ان يتخذ هذه الخطوات وان
يعلن عن نفسه لانه بهذه الطريقه وحدها
يحمي نفسه من ماذا من الاداره ووزاره عدل
وكل المشاكل القانونيه التي هي بانتظاره
في بدايه العام الماضي يعني هناك عدد كبير
من المعوقات التي ممكن ان يواجهها ترامب
من الان وحتى الانتخابات بدايه نتحدث عنه
الديمقراطيين هو الاداء في الفشل بموضوع
الضمان بموضوع البنيه التحتيه يعني بعدم
تحقيق جزء كبير من خطاب الانتخابيه لاي
مدى ممكن ان يستخدمه هذه النقطه بتوجيه
السهام
انا عندي تقدير مختلف عن بعض هذه التحاليل
اقول مشكله ترامب ليست الديمقراطيه يعني
سوف يقومون بحملات وقاموا بحملات لا مثيل
لها عندما كان في السلطه وعندما خرج عن
السلطه هذه نقطه قوه بالنسبه له لانه يحشد
المحافظين ويحشر الجمهوريين كلما تصاعدت
الاصوات الديمقراطيه المنتقده مشكلته
اثنين هنالك جزء من الطبقه السياسيه او
الاسلام كما قال الجمهوريه التي ستنتقده
وهذه تشكل خطر عليه
صحيح ولكن ما جرى هذه المره مختلف عن
الماضي ما كانوا يسموا نو ترامب كانوا جزء
بسيط الان فوكس نيوز وهي الشبكه الاكبر
عند المحافظين بدات تنتقده وتتموقع هناك
شبكتين اليوم
وايضا ايضا وسيله اعلاميه اخرى التي كانت
تتموضع الى جانب ترامب اليوم تتموضع الى
جانب خصمه ترامب ماذا يعني ذلك وكيف يمكن
ان تؤثر
لاشرح بعض التفاصيل فوكس نيوز هي الاكبر
وكان دائما الاكبر وكانت هي ال- ال- الرجل
او الاركان الركن الاساس لترامب في حملاته
يستعملها للوصول الى قواعد الشعبيه منذ
نهايه
برزت محطه اخرى هي نيوز ماكس تي في وهي
الان بحجم ثلث فوكس نيوز لم تصل بعد الى
فوكس نيوز فوكس نوس همم يعني من يملكها
همم قرر ان يكون ضد ترامب وقال لها بوضوح
والغريب العجيب بالنسبه لنا انها فوكسي
نيوز قالت انا لن امشي يعني مع
الديمقراطين ولكن ساختار مرشح اخر ضمن
الجمهوريين ومن هو هذا المرشح الذي تكلم
عنه في الالعاب
هذه مشكله ترامب الحقيقيه لانه ديسانتس هو
ترامب ولكن افضل مرشح كما يقول اخصامه هو
النجم الشاب للحزب الجمهوري كما يقولون
عنه اليوم همم ايضا من يعني من نقاط الضعف
التي يتحدثون عنها موضوع ال- المرشحين
الداخليين هناك عدد كبير اليوم يحاولون
مزاحمه ترامب في الداخل الى اي مدى
سيستطيعون التاثير عليها على ما يبدو
فقدنا الدكتور وليد فارس همم فقدنا
شوف حتى دكتور وليد
داخل حزب الجمهوري الى اي ماده هذا
الانقسام الداخلي ممكن ان يؤثر على معركه
ترامب وايضا المعركه القضائيه ضد ترامب
ساحه مختلفتان انا اقول اخطر ما عليه
عمليا هو معركه قضائيه لانه بامكانها ان
تشله يعني تصور اذا كان هنالك استدعاء من
قبل الاضاءه ولكن هذا قرار خطير جدا امام
اداره بيدن لانه معركه قضائيه اما ان
تضعفه اما ان تقويه بشكل غير طبيعي لانه
هنا دائما عطف على من هو يعني يهاجم او
يعني ينتقد من قبل الاداره ولكن عمليا ردا
على سؤالك سيدتي
ترامب لا يخاف من المرشحين على يساره كبوش
وكامي وكل هؤلاء يخاف من المرشحين على
يمينه خاصه اذا كانوا شبابا خاصه اذا
نجحوا في معارك بس كان بفلور ده او ال-
الجفر يمكن هنا في فرجينيا هؤلاء هم الذين
فعلا سوف يخاصموا وربما قام بخطا صغير لا
ادري الخبراء الانتخابيون يدرون اكثر
عندما هاجمهم قبل ان يهاجموا وهذا ما بناه
اليوم على السوشيال ميديا انه قاعدته تقول
له نحن معك ولكن لماذا تفتح هذه الجبهات
على هؤلاء الحكام وهم قد يكونوا معك لماذا
تفعل هذه المشاكل حملات سباقيه شكرا لك يا
دكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه حدثنا
محادثات الرئيسان الامريكي تشوبايدن
ونظيره الصيني شيت جنبيك تشير الى تحول في
العلاقات بين واشنطن وبكين نحو اداره
المنافسه الشرسه وفقا لصحيفه وصفه حيث تم
فتح قنوات خلفيه للمحادثات بين مستشارين
لبيضا وادي فلوماسيه صينيه كبير منذ اغسطس
الماضي وفقا للصحيفه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه النزاهه العراقيه عن تشكيل
هيئه العليا للتحقيق بقضايا الفساد الكبرى
ياتي القرار عقب تاكيد رئيس الحكومه
العراقيه محمد السوداني ان اولويه ولايته
تتمثل في مكافحه الفساد و خلال مؤتمر صحفي
بدايه الشهر الحالي وصف السودان الفساد
بالتهديد الخطير على الدوله العراقيه هذا
مباشره سلطات بعد ايام من تعيين الشهر
الماضي التحقيق في سرقه اثنين فصل خمسه
مليار دولار من اموال الهيئه العامه
للضرائب في مصر في الرافدين الحكومي وصدرت
مذكرات اعتقال بحق المتورطين فيها
قالت السفير الامريكيه لدى العراق في
مقابله مع العربيه ان العراقيين لا يريدون
امه تقودها الميليشيات وفقا لتعبيرها فن
تابع
قوله انه من العراقيين الذين التقيتهم
وتحدثت اليه من خلال الاشهر السته يبدو ان
العراقيين لا يريدون امه
بقيادته ميليشيا مسلحه بل يؤمنون انهم
يستحقون دوله
تصيروا
على السلاح وعلى وحكومه يمكن ان توفر
الامن والاستقرار والنمو الاقتصادي
للوفاء
بخدمات التي يحتاجها الشعب
مشاهدينا بالعوده للموضوع الاوكراني ساشير
الى هذه العواجل التي وردت الان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لعمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قد تشهد تباطن خلال الشتاء ورئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه يقول بان احتمال
دفع اوكرانيا روسيا للانسحاب من كل
اراضيها ضعيف اذا كانت هي هذه اخر العواجل
بالموضوع الاوكراني والان ايضا وزير اعلام
اليمن بشان اخر يقول بان استهداف ناقله في
بحر عمان امتداد للقرصنه والهاشمات
الايرانيه هذا كان طبعا بعد الهجوم التي
قامت به ايران عبر طائره مسيره لاحدى
ناقلات النفط في بحر عمان تابعونا في
التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
في الصومال سوء التغذيه يصيب طفلا كل
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وصل ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه
في زياره الرسميه وتعد هذه الزياره
الثانيه لولي العهد السعودي الى سول خلال
ثلاث سنوات ملفات اقتصاديه كبرى ستكون على
جدول الزياره بحضور كبرى الشركات الكوريه
ورجال الاعمال وذلك لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار
في السعوديه
ذكر السفير السعودي في العاصمه الكوريه
الجنوبيه سيول للعربيه انه سيقام على هامش
زياره ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا منتدى للاستثمار بحضور
كبرى الشركات الكوريه ورجال الاعمال وذلك
لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
لجذب الشركات
ورجال الاعمال
في لقاء مباشر مع الشركات
ورجال اعمال سعوديين ليتم بحث ومناقشه همم
فرص الاستثمار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لذلك هناك حماس كبير من الشركات
الكوريه في الدخول في شركات استراتيجيه
واستثماريه وتجاريه مع القطاع الخاص في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تربط السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه علاقات
متينه امتازت بالتوافق والتنسيق على كافه
المستويات السياسيه والاقتصاديه منها
نتعرف على بعض من محطاتها وما حققته خلال
الستين عاما الماضيه
60 عاما عمرو علاقات السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه جمعتهما توافقات عده في الكثير
من الجوانب السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه في منذ نشاتها في العام
1962 كان للبلدين محطات مهمه اقتصاديا
وتجاريا حيث شهدت العلاقات المشتركه منذ
بدايتها اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم اسهم في
جعل السعوديه من اوائل الشركاء التجاريين
لكوريا الجنوبيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
حيث كان من اهمها تاسيس اللجنه السعوديه
الكوريه المشتركه فيما شكل اطلاق رؤيه
السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 في العام 2017
نقطه تحول مهمه لتاسيس مرحله شراك اكبر في
قطاعات الاستراتيجيه منها النقل والطاقه
والاتصالات حيث تستهدف كوريا الجنوبيه من
خلالها ان تكون من ابرز الشركاء المساهمين
في تحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030
في العام 20 21 بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري
بين السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه نحو 26
مليار دولار في مسجل الميزان التجاري
فائضا لصالح السعوديه بقيمه 19 مليار
دولار
وعلى الصعيد الاستثمارات تعمل شركه سعوديه
مختلفه في السوق الكوريه من ابرزها
استثمار الم في السعوديه حيث تعمل من
خلالها اربعه مشاريع وشركتين تتجاوز
قيمتها الخمس مليارات دولار وايضا سابك
تعمل بحجم استثمارات بلغ مليار دولار
وفي الجهه المقابله بلغ عدد الاستثمارات
الكوريه في السعوديه
132 استثمارا باجمالي راس المال يتجاوز
ثلاث مليارات في قطاعات منها التعدين
والكهرباء والغاز
زياره ولي العهد السعودي
مع شركات كوريه والسعوديه في مختلف
المجالات مع توقعاتنا بجذب المزيد من
الاستثمارات الكوريه الى المملكه ميسون
ويهد العربيه سول كوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى الملف العراقيه تقول
بان اداره بايدون ابلغت رئيس وزراء العراق
بانها لن تعمل مع وزراء منتمين الى فصائل
ارهابيه وايضا اداره بيض رفضت التعامل مع
وزير التعليم العراقي المنتمي لعصائب اهل
الحق اذا كان هذا الموقف الامريكي من
الحكومه التي تعتبر مواليه لايران الى
الصومال حيث قالت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف ان هناك ارتفاع غير مسقوق
في معدلات وفيات الاطفال على خلفيه الجفاف
وسوء التغذيه الحاد واضافت المنظمه في اخر
تقرير عن وضع الاطفال في الصومال الى انه
يتم تشخيص اصابه الطفل كل دقيقه بسوء
التغذيه حيث يهدد الجفاف الشديد بارتفاع
في معدل وفيات الاطفال في البلاد
لم تملك هذه السيده سوى الفراري نحو
العاصمه وقديشو بعد ان خطف الموت ثلاثه من
اطفالها بسبب سوء التغذيه الناتجه عن
الجفاف العارمه الذي يضرب البلاد خديجه
معه التي نزحت من منطقه سبلا لبي محافظه
شبل السفلى بالجنوب تعيش في حاله قلقنا
دائما جراء الظروف المعيشه صعبه خاصه وان
لديها طفلين اخرين تتمنى ان يعيش في حاله
افضل في البيئه الجديده التي تفتقد هي
الاخرى الى ابسط مقومات العيش الكريم
وتوفي ثلاثه من اطفال بسبب الحصبه وسوء
التغذيه وما زال الاطفال هنا يعانون سوء
التغذيه ويزداد وضع اطفال النازحين سوءا
يوما بعد اخر مع اشتداد حاله الجفاف في
البلاد حيث لا تتوقف حركه النزوح تجاه
مخيمات على اطراف مقدسه بحث عن امن وغذاء
وصلت الى هذه المنطقه منذ شهر ونعاني من
الجوع مع اطفالي وامي العجوز نريد دعما
عاجلا خاصه للضعفاء منا
وبحسب منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله فان
معادله وفيات الاطفال نتيجه سوء التغذيه
في الشمال يشهد ارتفاعا مخيفا وان الوضع
اسوا مما كان عليه عام 2011 عندما تسببت
للمجاعه في وفاه ربع مليون صوماليه عبد
الرحمن بخاري العربي
[موسيقى]
بعد نصف قرن على اخر رحله امريكيه الى
القمر من هذا النوع ناسا اطلقت الصاروخ
الاقوى في العالم مدشنه عصرا جديدا هذه
المره يضمن نقل طواقم بشريه الى القمر في
السنوات المقبله واقامه وجود بشري دائم
على القمر وبناء محطه فضائيه في مداره
واطلقت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا مهمات
ارتمسوان غير الماهوله الى القمر في اعقاب
العديد من التاخيرات بسبب مشكلات فنيه
وسوء الاحوال الجويه هذا واطلق ارتم
اسطوانه الذي يصل ارتفاعه الى 100 متر الى
السماء ليتسبب في مزيج مذهل من الصوت
والضوء حيث سيكون الهدف الرئيسي من هذه
الحمله الاستكشافيه التي ستستمر ل 25 يوما
نقل طواقم مستقبليه الى القمر ويشكل هذا
الحدث الانطلاق الكبيره لبرنامج ارتميس
حيث سيتم الاقتراب من القمر عندما سوف تصل
الى اربعه و60000 كم في رقم القياسي
لمركبه قابله للسكن ضمن رحله هي الاولى من
نوعها ضمن برنامج ارتميس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
قال الملك الجديد منصه تويتر الى ماسك انه
سيتم اعاده اطلاق الاشتراك في خدمه علامه
التحقق الزرقاء على تويتر في 29 من نوفمبر
في تاخير طفيف عن جدوله الزمنيه المبدئي
لاعاده الخدمه على منصه التواصل الاجتماعي
وقال ماسك انه في الاصدار الجديد
سيؤدي تغيير الاسم الذي تم التحقق منه الى
فقدان العلامه الزرقاء حتى يتم تاكيد
الاسم من قبل تويتر للوفاء بشروط الخدمه
نختم مشاهدينا مع هذا الخبر حيث من المقرر
طرح قطعتين من الاثاث كانتا مملكتين لملكه
فرنسا ماري انطوانات في مزاد يوم الثاني
والعشرين من نوفمبر جاري في باريس وتقدر
قيمه الخزانه ذات الادراج والكرسي البالغه
من العمر 250 عاما ما بين 800,000 واحد
فاصله اثنين مليون يورو ومائه الف ومائتين
الف يورو على التوالي
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله الان الى الزميل طاهر
و360 وطبعا قبل ان انتقل اليك طاهر كنا
تبعنا العواجل الاخيره التي اصدرتها
الاداره الامريكيه بخصوص السفينه او
الاستهداف الايراني
النفط في بحر عمان